hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
before we begin we want to cover a few
housekeeping items
for any common technical issues please
refer to the help widget located at the
bottom of your screen
this webinar was pre-recorded and is
being presented with a live q a
if you're tuning in for the initial
webcast you can submit questions via the
q a widget on the left side of your
screen
the researchers will be answering them
via the widget in real time
also stick around after the webinar for
the live q
a when the researchers will dive deeper
on popular questions asked
additional resources and links provided
from today's presentation
can be found in the resource list on the
right side of your screen
an on-demand version of the webinar will
be available approximately one day after
the initial webcast
and can be accessed using the same
audience link that was sent to you
earlier
on-demand viewers will get to hear the
recorded version of the live q a
enjoy the webinar hello everybody my
name is josh benello
i'm the senior principal cryptographer
here at microsoft research
and i'm going to be talking to people
today about microsoft's election guard
technology
which allows people to verify that their
votes have been correctly counted
so i'm going to start by talking about
a report that was done a couple years
ago by the national academy of science
engineering and medicine
looking at the state of elections in
in the u.s we know
that confidence in elections is at uh
somewhat of a low these days and
we're looking at at the situation and
trying to understand what we can do to
improve it
so um the findings of the report
included many elements
and i'll just touch on a few first of
all
there is abundant evidence um
really no question about the fact that
there was
extensive russian intrusion into the
2016 election
mostly in the form of disinformation
attacks on voter registration databases
and and other um forms of attack
however it's important to note that
there
is no evidence that i've seen or the
people i've spoken to have seen
of tampering with the actual votes
nevertheless
we know that our electoral system is
extremely vulnerable
there are many ways in which tampering
of votes could happen
and we want to talk about ways in which
we can tell what's happening and deal
with it
so we know that we must apply
the best practices that we can in order
to try to improve our voting systems
to try to bring things up to the best
standards that we can
however we know that this is not
sufficient and
the reason is the challenge here is
asymmetric
in the u.s elections are run locally
mostly by
counties sometimes even by townships
there are only two states
that run elections at a statewide level
yet the attackers
can be nation states and
it's it's simply not reasonable for us
to expect
that a small county government
with likely a very small i.t department
can withstand an attack from
the russian fsb or apt-1 in shanghai or
north korea or many other nation-state
attackers
so we have to accept that yes we should
do things to try to
improve security but that's
just not going to be enough we can't
reasonably expect to make our election
systems
impervious to attack however
even though we can't ensure that our
election systems
can't be attacked we can detect it
um and what it says is that
auditing of elections is essential and
there are things that we can do
to make sure that we know what's
happened so
um in this national academies report
we recommended two particular kinds of
auditing
one is a risk limiting audit
sort of an administrative audit and the
other
is a public form of auditing called
end-to-end verifiability
i'll speak very briefly about risk
limiting audits
this is a fairly new technology to be
more efficient about the kind of audits
that you might think of traditionally
traditionally in an audit
what happens is people will select
uh ballots in some form at random
and then see if these things
confirm the tally either by uh
converging
on the tally slowly or um
in in better uh circumstances by
matching them
directly against electronic records uh
that can make it more far more efficient
the risk limiting approach uses um
more sophisticated statistics to make
the audit process
dynamic rather than what we've
traditionally seen where maybe there's a
fixed percentage of ballots that are
audited or fixed percentage of precincts
that are audited
a risk limiting audit allows auditors to
to know how many ballots need to be
checked in order to
confirm the uh the accuracy of of the
outcome of the election the other kind
of auditing that we talked about in the
national academies report
is a technique called end-to-end
verifiability an
end-to-end verifiability uses
cryptography
to allow public auditing members of the
public
can check for themselves that the
election outcome is correct that their
votes have been accurately recorded
and that all of the recorded votes have
been accurately tallied
so to get into a little bit more detail
about end-to-end verifiability
what end-to-end verifiability achieves
is that
any inaccuracies any tampering in an
election
can be detected and when i say can be
detected i'm not just speaking about
detection by
election officials the detection can be
done
by candidates by the media by individual
voters or other observers
it's a public verifiability anybody can
check that the
election has been properly conducted and
is accurate
and this is not just limited to external
tampering
this enables detection of corruption by
election officials by equipment vendors
by others even kinds of tampering that
have not yet been imagined
end-to-end verifiability enables us to
see
if the outcome of an election is correct
so at this point i should give a
slightly more formal definition there
are really two aspects to end-to-end
verifiability
the first is that voters can verify
their own selections have been
accurately recorded
and then anyone can verify that the
recorded votes
have been accurately tallied and this is
more or less the most that that you can
reasonably expect
to be done you can't expect anyone to be
able
to verify that an individual vote
matches the voter selections
without knowing what that voter's
selections were and this would violate
privacy of the ballot so this is pretty
much the most we can hope for
it seems very strong but actually
it's not that hard to achieve so
let me describe how we can achieve
end-to-end verifiability very easily
here is
a public ledger of an election all the
names of the voters are listed
all their votes are listed the totals
are listed
and now anyone who voted can check to
see that their vote has been accurately
recorded
and anyone can look at this ledger and
see that
the recorded votes have been accurately
tallied it's actually a very easy thing
to achieve
um of course um if you're thinking a
little bit ahead you may
realize that i've kind of skipped
something important and that there's no
privacy in that public ledger
and privacy is critical to
most elections certainly public
elections secret ballot elections
it's a very strong requirement it's not
just that voters
are able to cast votes in private it's
that voters
must be unable to disclose their votes
to others even
if they want to if voters are
able to disclose their votes then they
can be coerced into voting in certain
ways they can sell their votes they can
do other things
that we really don't want voters to be
able to do
so to protect voters voters should
not be able to show anybody else how
they voted
of course if we didn't have this
requirement
the the last slide that i showed would
finish the talk
things would be very easy we can have a
nice secure bulletin board a web page
with
everybody's vote and we'd be done now
this
is not something that is
extraordinarily unusual
most u.s presidents were elected
without the benefit of a secret ballot
secret ballots
are a relatively new technology
dating back to the 1850s i believe in
australia
is where they were first used
and then in the 1880s in the u.s
is where they first became prominent
it may not seem like a technological
advance but the idea of
voters being able to vote
within a public environment but
privately
within that public environment where
their privacy is being publicly
monitored and publicly enforced
was a new idea before that
we didn't really have good ways of
having secret ballot elections so we had
you know what's shown in this famous
portrait uh
people going to the public square and
effectively announcing
one at a time what their votes were
of course this creates a lot of problems
and
this is something we want to avoid so
i'm going to go back to this public
end-to-end verifiable election
and show how we can take this and make
just
a small tweak to it and
achieve a private a secret
end-to-end verifiable election and the
trick is basically
to have the same public listing
but instead to encrypt
all of the selections made by every
voter all of the actual ballots
so instead of seeing the actual
selection made by a voter
you would see the encryption or an
encryption of the selection made by a
voter
now if we're showing only encrypted
votes
we need a couple of things to achieve
end-to-end verifiability
we need to provide a way for a voter
carol in this case
to know that the encryption that's
that corresponds to her vote actually
matches her selection adams in this case
we also need to have a way of taking
this list of encrypted
votes and showing that these encrypted
votes correspond to the announced
tallies
now these are possible and i'll show how
to do them
but once we have that we can achieve a
secret ballot end-to-end verifiable
election
so we have two questions that have to be
answered
the first is what do voters do to turn
their preferences into encrypted votes
and the second is how are voters
convinced
that the published set of encrypted
votes
corresponds to the announced tally okay
those are the the two issues we've had
to
uh to deal with and i'm gonna deal with
the second
one first um for a variety of reasons
it's sort of the more compact and and
mathematically rigorous um also the
first
um historically in the the
history of end to end verifiability
so let's talk about encryption a little
bit at this point
there are um a lot of things that one
can do with
encryption but typically encryption is a
static thing
the only thing that's typically done
with encrypted data
is it is eventually decrypted it might
be
put into storage and then removed from
storage and then decrypted
it may be transmitted from one person to
another
and decrypted by the recipient it can
move around a lot
but the encrypted data rarely changes
as it's stored as it's moved around the
only thing that is typically done with
it
is decryption but that's not the only
thing that can be done with it
it is actually possible to compute on
encrypted data
in encrypted form some encryption
methods
allow that computation to be done on two
encrypted values so you could take
two encrypted values and combine them in
some way
to form a new encryption which
represents some function of the two
values
so this notion is typically called
homomorphic encryption
and i'll give a couple of examples of
how this can be done
first it's possible for us to construct
encryption functions
such that if big a is an encryption of
little a
and big b is encryption of little b then
if we multiply the two encryptions we
get something which is an encryption
of the product of the the plain text the
unencrypted values
simple enough um and many
um modern encryption systems actually
achieve this
if you know of rsa encryption it has
this property
we can also construct an encryption
function that if you take
an encryption of little a an encryption
of little b
and multiply the encryptions together
you get an encryption of the sum now you
might think what you have to do is add
the encryptions together but for various
technical reasons
it usually works much better to multiply
the encryptions
but that will be an encryption of the
sum
of the initial values okay so why is
this interesting in particular when
we're talking about elections
well in an election if we take
an encryption of the first vote
encryption of the second vote and
go on through all the votes all we
really need to do
is add up the votes palling an election
is
nothing more than simple encryption a
simple addition
so all we have to do is take the product
of these encryptions
and we get an encryption of the sum
and the sum is our goal the sum is the
tally of the election
so let's take a look in a little bit
more detail of what a ballot might look
like
a ballot could be thought of as just
a vector an array of zeros and ones
perhaps one means an option was selected
zero means it's not selected
we might have multiple contests in an
election
and multiple options per contest so in
this ballot
we see in the first contest the second
option was selected and the second
contest the first
option was selected and then the third
contest the voter
uh chose not to select any options
okay so if we have a whole
set of votes that are of this form
then all we're doing is adding up the
columns
and going down each column
getting the column sums that's the tally
of the election
nothing more than simple addition of
zeros and ones
so if we have an ability to do
addition underneath encryption where
we've encrypted
ballots encrypted the votes and then we
can add them
without decrypting we can achieve
something very valuable here
so imagine that these are now encrypted
ballots they're
covered up you can't really see what's
under them unless you look
very hard i have special powers of some
sort here
what we could do is multiply these
encryptions together
again by columns so there is an
encryption of every 0
and 1 here and we're just multiplying
down the columns and getting new
encryptions down at the bottom
and then we decrypt just
this amalgamated tally value at the
bottom
and we're getting a tally worth actually
a set of tallies
in this election without having to
decrypt the original
votes the original ballots okay so this
gives a sense of what we might be able
to do with
this technique of homomorphic encryption
in order
to enable ballast to be
kept private kept secure and still allow
a publicly verifiable tally that
looks the way it would have had
all the ballots been opened in the first
place
okay so there are a few things we need
to
to mention about this encryption to get
everything right
first of all it's important to realize
that this encryption is randomized
you never want it to be the case that uh
two identical votes will encrypt exactly
the same way
because then you could tell oh your vote
is the same as mine because
the encryptions are the same so we need
this randomization
um to prevent identical ballots from
having identical
encryptions so the actual encryption
method
will take uh selections from
a voter will take some randomness and
put them together to form an encryption
and if you take a particular selection
and particular randomness you'll get a
particular encryption
and if you change the randomness you'll
change the encryption
even without changing the the selections
made
so once we have that we also have
a way of creating a verifiable
decryption of a ballot as long as this
encryption is done with some
public method public key encryption
then we can prove that
a decryption is correct by just
releasing the random information
in this case if we say
that adams is the raw ballot and this
random value
is this long number that begins with 667
then somebody can put these things
through the encrypter
and see that they match the encrypted
ballot that it's supposed to and say oh
well i guess that encrypted ballot
really does decrypt
atoms all we have to do
is release this random value and this
random value serves as a key to the
decryption
so who should be able to do this
compute these random values and figure
things out
well we don't want there to be some one
single entity who can decrypt everything
that's you know much too powerful and a
an entity
that entity could see how everybody
voted and we want to avoid that
so we want to split the decryption
capabilities
amongst some sort of a canvassing board
and that's the traditional
um group in elections in the u.s
that makes decisions looks at ambiguous
ballots
and decides whether a particular vote
counts or not
in most jurisdictions there's some
canvassing board or equivalent that
maybe consists of three members or five
members
who make the decisions about
the details of eligibility and other
decisions and ballots
so um this canvassing board is natural
to be a group that is given this
capability of decryption and they have
to work together
to perform a decryption so they could
decrypt
the tally of the election say so
we want to split the decryption
functionality amongst the members of
this canvassing board
and it turns out it's not that hard to
do it
but we're going to take this a step
further we don't want
to require all the members of the
canvassing board to cooperate
in order to decrypt there are
things that can go wrong it's just too
many things that can go wrong
one of the members of the canvassing
board could lose
a key or a hardware or
device of some sort that enables the
decryption
maybe one member of the canvassing board
is unhappy for some reason
sees things are going in a particular
way and doesn't like it and refuses to
cooperate to decrypt
so we want to build in a little bit of
robustness
and what would do is use threshold
encryption in particular since we're
using homomorphic encryption we have to
use threshold homomorphic encryption
which allows us to set
parameters and say there are five
canvassing board members
we might want to say any three of them
together
can perform decryption or we could say
four or
two two is probably too small but
three a majority is a reasonable number
here
so we've talked a
bit about how ballots are
uh encrypted and the encryptions
are tallied but now we have to get
back to question one what it is that
voters do to turn their preferences into
encrypted votes
and this is a little tricky right
because now you're asking
humans to encrypt in some way how
can a human being turn
preferences into an encrypted ballot
this seems like
it's it's a hard task but there are some
tricks that make this possible
so i have a volunteer here who i'm going
to work with to show
how voters can be confident in the
correct encryption of their votes
so what i have here is an ordinary deck
of cards i have
no magical skills whatsoever sorry to
say
and there are really just two kinds of
votes in this deck there are red votes
there are black votes this is a black
vote
this is an encryption of a black vote
you can't see what this black vote is
unless it's
decrypted so i'm going to ask you as a
voter
to select how you want to vote so
you have two choices red or black would
you like a red vote or a black vote
okay so now what i'm going to do is put
down
several cards
and allow you to choose whichever card
you want just by pointing to it don't
touch it don't turn it over just okay
so this is going to be your vote so what
i'm going to do is turn over this one
this one this one and this one and now
you can see that
all the other cards that you didn't
select were all black
therefore you have some reason to
believe that this card is black as well
you don't have absolute certainty in it
but
you have good confidence the only way
that i could have cheated you
and had this be a red card is if somehow
i had predicted in advance that
you were going to choose this card and
my chance of doing that is
probably not more than 20 in this case
so this gives you an idea
of how i can convince you that
your unseen vote in this case this card
that you haven't seen
which you believe is black but you don't
know whether it's
a club or a spade you don't know its
rank i'll turn it over
it turned out to be the six of clubs but
at this point
you didn't know what it was but
you could follow this card through the
system you could virtually write your
name on the back of it and follow it
through the system
and see that this is your vote and it's
being counted
now of course we're not really going to
make multiple ballots for voters and ask
them to choose which ballot
to select so what we really do with
voters
is something a little bit simpler which
i like to call
the world's most boring card trick so
what i'm going to do is allow you to
select
a vote i'll put down what i claim to be
the correct vote
and allow you to say whether or not you
want to keep it
and we'll do that just just for the sake
of argument here i'll encourage you to
to look at at least a few cards just
just to show things although most voters
will not look at any
so for your first vote would you like
red or black
okay red claim that's a red vote would
you like to see it
yeah yeah yes turns out it is a red vote
okay this time would you like a red vote
or a black vote
okay you like to see this one yes
it turns out to be black as well red or
black
black okay would you like to see this
one
okay that one's black as well
red or black red
would you like to see this one not this
time yeah i told you with the world's
most boring quadratic you've gotten
bored already
so this is going to be your vote and
because i didn't know where you were
going to stop and where
um you're going to say i want that vote
yes that
only if i had somehow guessed what
card you were going to stop on could i
have
given you the wrong vote here could i
have given you a black vote when you
asked for a red vote
without your noticing it now this will
be your vote
you could virtually write your name on
the back of it and follow it through the
system
you have confidence that it's a red vote
but
you have no way of showing anybody else
what it is you
again you don't know whether it's a
heart or a diamond you don't know it's
rank
until i reveal it which i'm doing in
this case just for show to show that
really is
what it was supposed to be thank you
very much for your help
the statistics are very much on our side
here
the statistics say that it's okay
if only a tiny tiny fraction of voters
actually
take advantage of this option and spoil
their ballots
even if very very few voters do this
in a sufficiently large election so as
an example
if a hundred voters in a national
election with maybe a hundred
million votes cast um each spoil
um a ballot and this is sort of randomly
distributed
throughout the the electorate then
a malicious system trying to
to steal votes trying to cheat in some
way by
flipping votes will likely be caught
if they try to flip more than one
percent of the votes and
you know if i flip it around another way
if
one percent of voters in an election
check then
it's very difficult to imagine more than
100 votes
being flipped without it being caught
so a very very small percentage is
enough to get
very high confidence in the accuracy of
an election
so what does an election record look
like at this point
well we have various elements
we have all of the cast ballots
and a mathematical proof that the cast
ballots are correct
um and um sorry that they're they
correspond to the tally
that that has been announced um we have
all of the spoiled ballots
and their decryptions voters don't need
to individually check
that the decryptions match their
selections
because again voters are not going to be
able to do
mathematics in a poll site they're not
going to want to they're not going to
want to check the decryption
but they actually don't have to the the
decryption of their ballots
is now public and part of a public
record
so anybody checking the public record
can check that the
decryptions are correct so even a
diligent voter
need only look and say oh i spoiled this
ballot
and now i look at the public website and
say oh that spoiled ballot
is listed as corresponding to the
selections that i made and
as long as that matches that
achieves um a a good challenge
and then the voter can leave it to
others or the voter can
do by oneself
the verification of all the artifacts
produced in the
the election record so
the cast ballots of course we've seen
this before
they correspond to zeros and ones in
encrypted form
and if we open them we can see that
these test ballots
correspond to what we would get if we
multiplied the encryptions
and that matches the summation
of the original balance so
the product of the encryptions of the
cast ballots correspond to an encryption
of the tally
and in practice what what we do
is just multiply together the cast
ballots and
decrypt in a verifiable way that anybody
can check
that the decryption really does match
the announced tallies
the spoiled ballots are also decrypted
and there are
verification proofs included for all of
the spoiled ballots
and for the the tally
so what does this look like for a voter
well it can look pretty much
like any traditional election system it
could look
like walking up to a device
that's got some nice accessibility
features
maybe even an audio channel for voters
with visual disabilities
and maybe brightness
and other ways of changing contrast
and that device can be used to mark
a ballot on a touch screen
voter could also hand mark a ballot and
put it into a scanner
pretty much anything that you think of
as a traditional
in-person voting system can be used
with an end-to-end verifiable system but
there's
one addition in an end-to-end verifiable
system
and that is the tracking code that the
voter
receives and gets to take home so this
tracking code
might look like an encryption or
something derived from the encryption of
a ballot
might say here is where you voted and
when
and here is your tracking code here is
basically
the encryption of your selections
now again since it's encryption you
can't use this to show anybody else how
you voted so
it doesn't allow you to be coerced or to
sell your vote
but it does allow you to track your vote
through the system
make sure it hasn't been changed and
because you can spoil a ballot
you can get confidence that this
encryption really does match your
selections
so from the voter's perspective voters
can
use these tracking codes to check their
results
and make sure that their their votes are
properly recorded on a public website
and
what we have found is that a reasonable
percentage of voters
seem to do that if we make it easy if
the receipt says
here's this website that you can go to a
reasonable fraction of voters seem to go
to this website and look up their
tracking codes and make sure that
they're there
or do what probably most voters will do
is take these tracking codes look at
them maybe with a little
question crumble them up and throw them
in the trash
that's okay we don't need every voter
to track votes we just need a reasonable
percentage of voters
to engage in this step voters
can also write their own election
verifiers
where they will go through all of the
artifacts
produced by an election and make sure
everything is correct everything is
consistent and the tallies match up
they can do that i don't reasonably
expect that most voters will but some
could
more likely voters will just download
verifiers
from other sources and run them
themselves and see oh yeah all the
artifacts in this election check out
there are people who are writing
verifiers right now
for this kind of technology and
hopefully there will be many verifiers
available so that
you as a voter might not do this but
maybe
your niece is taking a computer science
class
and wrote a verifier is a step in this
and you get your nieces verifier and run
it and
on your election and it says good great
that's a good step
more likely people will just believe
verifications done by third parties
their their their candidates
their favorite political party league of
women voters aclu
other interest groups of various sorts
news media
and say okay you were able to verify
this election it's good
i'm happy i didn't have to verify it
myself
or voters can do pretty much what they
do today
because they don't have any choice today
and that's
accept the results with no question they
can just
say okay here it is i don't care
i don't have to do anything it's
critically important that we not
force voters to do anything that they're
not doing today we're just giving them
new capabilities
so what's in one of these verifiers
well there are a few things that have to
be included
um verifier first of all
has to check that the cast ballots
are correctly combined to form
an encrypted tally it's just checking
the multiplications
so if we look here basically saying
okay all these columns multiply out to
the bottom
um and it's just a simple check
but anybody should be able to check that
a verifier also should check the
decryption of the tally make sure that's
correct
so that's just opening that making sure
that
that does match with the artifacts that
have been provided
a verifier should verify that all the
spoiled ballots
were correctly decrypted as well so
that's this step
over here where you take all the spoiled
ballots and you open those
and the verifier should go through and
make sure all of those spoiled ballots
were correctly opened
but there's one more step that i'm
leaving out
and this is perhaps the most subtle
i often can go through and talk about
this without anybody
thinking of this and realizing it but
some of you may be thinking this is
important right now
and that is verifiers must check that
every encrypted ballot is well formed
what do i mean by that
well we we showed earlier what a ballot
might look like
it it may look like um a a
vector of of zeros and ones
so this is what a valid ballot could
look like
here's a ballot that might not be valid
maybe this ballot has
two votes in the first contest and
in this election you're only allowed to
vote once in the first contest
there are some elections where it's okay
you can vote for up to two or up to
three or something like that
but if this is an election where you're
only allowed to vote
for one selection in the first contest
and this ballot has two selections made
in the first contest
it's not valid let me show you another
invalid ballot this one is definitely
invalid
one where there are 101 votes in this
one ballot
cast for the second option and negative
100 votes
cast for the fourth option so the totals
will match up and the total number of
ballots the total number of votes would
match up if you
you have even one single ballot in an
election that looks like this
but of course the tallies will not be
correct so
one critical thing and this is where
most of the work in a verifier is
is to go through a ballot
every ballot in fact and make sure that
every encryption on that ballot is
either an encryption of zero or an
encryption of one
without knowing which and there are ways
of doing this
they're non-interactive zero knowledge
proofs is the technique that's
that's used here and these proofs are
provided to show that
each selection is either an encryption
of zero or an encryption of one
without showing which and the verifier
will go
and check that this proof is correct so
that
every entry in the ballot
is well-formed that the number of
selections made in any contest
doesn't exceed the limit of the number
of selections made
and once you have that you really do
have
full verification so there are really
just
four operations that need to be done in
in a verifier
the first is modular addition adding
things
mod a prime in this case
modular multiplication just doing a
multiplication
and taking that value modulo again
another prime
modular exponentiation raising
a base to a power mod
again a prime here of course
this with the large numbers that we're
using
can't be done by just exponentiating and
then reducing you have to
have some sort of a tool that will go
through and
do this modular exponentiation
with reductions as you go
and the final tool that needs to be
included in a verifier
is a sha-256 hash this is a standard
hash function
these are all readily available there
are packages in many languages
that will do this python has modular
addition multiplication and
exponentiation
of large integers built in but many
other languages
have this so it is a reasonable
task for you as an individual or maybe
you as a professor to assign to a
student
either as a class project or an
independent study project
to write an election verifier
that uses these technologies and can be
used
by the author and by others to verify
elections
so more information is available
election guard has
been deployed as
an open source free
toolkit microsoft is working
with election vendors
to build election guard into new and
existing
systems we're not trying to
make money out of this this is not
something that we're selling
this is something that we're doing for
public good
um and we are encouraging
vendors to use this and working with
vendors to try to
get the details right and
the the toolkit is available at
github.com microsoft slash election
guard
there's a detailed specification that
goes through all the
mathematics and all the organization and
the structure
that's also available on that website
and
there is a verifier that has been
written in
rust as a reference
that is also available we have
run our first public election with
election guard
it was done in fulton wisconsin
and seemed very successful and we're
that was our first pilot we we are
looking
to have many more pilots and try to get
this technology as
widely deployed as possible uh and then
verifiability is a
great tool for enabling members of the
public to check
that their votes have been properly
counted so thank you everyone
if you'd like to stay around i will be
answering some of the best questions
that have been submitted
and hope to explain more about this
technology
and give you a chance to understand it
and
use it for yourselves thank you
all right thank you everyone um thank
you for
listening this is josh benello now with
you live
um i hope you enjoyed the the webcast
and i'm going to try now to
answer some of the questions that came
up a whole bunch of questions came up at
the
in at the last moment so i i've tried to
look over them but if i don't get to
your question my apologies
you can try to talk to me off offline
if anything is not fully addressed here
the first thing i would like to try to
address is that
there were many questions um having to
do with the
process of spoiling ballots so i want to
try to clarify that a little bit uh that
was described a little bit in the card
trick
that was done but i'd
like to get give a better sense of how
that fits into the actual process of
voting
so this is
intended by the way principally for
in-person voting although i can talk a
little bit more about
some alternatives but
imagine that somebody is voting in
person
and they go through a process maybe
they're
working with a device an electronic
device and they're making their
preferences known
maybe they're hand marking a paper
ballot there are a variety of mechanisms
they complete the process they then go
to the next step
of partially submitting this vote um it
would
perhaps be the last step on on a screen
or might be putting a handmark ballot
into a scanner
and they would at that point receive a
tracking code
now that tracking code is a commitment
to the ballot that they have created
but it is not yet representing a cash
ballot
voters still have an opportunity at that
time
to cancel their ballot and restart
and retain the tracking codes that they
have received
so a voter could at that time
spoil or cancel a ballot spoil as kind
of a term of art in the election
industry
that just says i want her to cancel a
ballot and restart it
so they would have an opportunity to
cancel their ballot
and then restart
and submit a new ballot and they could
even
cancel the second ballot now we do not
by any means require every voter to do
this um
a very small fraction of voters probably
fewer than one percent
will actually spoil balance ballots
might be spoiled for a variety of
reasons it might be
that a voter spoils a ballot as
part of the the process because they
look at the end at a paper ballot and
they say well i made a mistake i want to
spoil my ballot and we start to correct
it
or they might spoil a ballot to actually
create an explicit challenge
um and and either way
it works with the system by by saying
spoiled ballots
will be opened there will be no names
associated with them
no names associated with any ballots in
general
but the spoiled ballots will be publicly
open decrypted and they serve as a check
in the same way that the card trick
described
anybody who spoils a ballot might be
doing so
to just test to make sure that it opens
it decrypts in the way that they expect
and hope
so that's the the principal reason
that we have for spoiling and the
principal mechanism
that is available for spoiling is just
that
in person you decide i
i think i want to challenge one ballot
or maybe even a super diligent voter of
my challenge
a second ballot and make sure that those
were
encrypted correctly and that gives
confidence in the system that it's
encrypting the cast out
correctly as well okay um
while i'm mentioning that i will say a
few things about
um the um the use the mode of voting
it's easiest to think of this for
in-person voting
the technology can be used for internet
voting
although we are not recommending it
because there are other
challenges with internet voting um
as i think i said um
internet voting if you're going to do it
you really should use this technology
the us vote foundation had
reports saying that you must use this
technology if you're going to do
responsible internet voting but that
it's not sufficient
there are still other challenges other
problems that need to be solved
voting over the internet or via
smartphones
or any other
remote voting scenario of that sort
vote by mail actually can
also be done with this technology but
the challenge is how would you do
this cancellation spoiling process
there are a few tricks there are a few
possibilities
i'm not going to go into it now but i'd
be happy to
to speak with people offline if there
are thoughts and ideas
about what you might want to do in your
local jurisdiction
we are trying to work with many
jurisdictions right now
and many vendors right now to
encourage interest it's of course a very
challenging time
three four months ago people were a lot
more interested
in innovation in elections um right now
the interest is a little bit more
towards surviving elections
so um the things have been
slowed down a little bit but this is a
long-term goal
we are probably not going to have a
tremendous
change tremendous use of this technology
for
2020 but we'd like to see it deployed as
widely as possible
for 2022 2024.
another question that came up a couple
times was homomorphic encryption
and the uh the use of it here um
i should explain it a little further
because homomorphic encryption
can mean a couple of different things
it's actually a very old technology
dates back more than 30 years
i believe i was actually the first to
use the term
homomorphic encryption although i'm not
100 sure of it
um and i don't want to take too much
credit for it because
um there was actually a paper written by
rivest adelman and dutuzos on
privacy homomorphisms and when i
needed to use the technology
in encryption and decryption rather than
just for
privacy functions it was a natural term
to apply because it had been there
but anyway it's existed for more than 30
years
but it was always kind of a niche thing
because you could do it with one
operation you could do it with addition
or multiplication but not for general
computation
uh just over 10 years ago uh craig
gentry
discovered a way of doing fully
homomorphic encryption which is
homomorphic encryption
that can do both addition and
multiplication on the same encrypted
values
and once you have that that's what's
called expressively complete
you can actually do any computation it's
a very powerful technology
the problem is that fully homowork
encryption
is much much slower originally
it was absurdly slow and you couldn't do
any
computations at all it's been improved a
great deal
over the last 10 years but still
except for fairly simple computations
it is very slow very cumbersome adds a
great deal of overhead
and is just not practical except for a
fairly simple computations but that's
not what we're doing here we're using
simple
homomorphic encryption that predated
fully homomorphic encryption
it's very very efficient it's just
doing additions and nothing more so that
makes
this much much easier to do um
let's see another question that came up
a couple times was
on verifiability
in um vv paths some people call it
voter verified paper trails or paper
auto trails um this
exists in some places but it's certainly
not enough to do end-to-end
verifiability
end-to-end verifiability goes to the
heart of the system
and allows you to check not just
that your vote um is on paper somewhere
and was supposedly counted correctly
it allows you to actually check the
counting and make sure
that your vote is amongst
all of the votes that were counted that
your vote
was correctly encrypted and matches your
selections
and that the um the the encrypted votes
were accurately tallied and all of this
of course with
the critical factor of your
not being able to show anybody else how
you voted
so that you can't be coerced you can't
sell your vote
these are are critical to any election
and we we need to make sure
that we've covered these very very
carefully
let's see another question
that came up a little bit is on the zero
knowledge proofs
i mentioned
briefly the challenges of
how to actually prove
that ballots are well-formed i didn't go
into that at all
there's existing technology in the field
of cryptography
for proving information about encrypted
values
without revealing undue information
so there are techniques due to
sean pedersen kramer domguard
schumachers
others that allow you to do things like
prove that an encrypted value
is an encryption of a zero or a one
without revealing which and that's
what's done here and
that is what can be
checked by a verifier there were also a
couple of questions about
verifiers themselves and how hard they
are to write
and who can write them i'm currently
working
with students at a few universities
um to write verifiers the first few will
probably be a little bit more
challenging as we get some of the bugs
out
and address some of the more difficult
things but
this should not be too hard a thing to
do this is the sort of thing that a
student can do
as a small student project um and the
expectation
is that there will be many verifiers out
there
so if you'd like to learn about this
more
look at the the spec look at what's in
github we have a sample verifier there
and you can use that but i encourage
anybody who's interested to go through
and
see exactly what needs to be written and
write their own
election verifiers in order to
check elections and once you write a
verifier it's not just for a single
election
it's for all elections using this
particular design
of course you know their uh end-to-end
verifiability can be done in many
different ways
and there might be different parameters
and
different uses but if if we take
election guard as it currently stands
that
is one system and
one verifier for election guard can
be used to verify many many
different elections using this
particular technology
so the hope is that we will have many
verifiers out there
and that people who are interested in
doing so could
download verifiers either from random
sites
or from sites that they trust that
i certainly wouldn't encourage running
something off of a random site that they
don't trust
but you can download these things as
apps and they can be
contained and firewalled if you're
concerned about them
and run them against
any elections that you are interested in
to verify
that the election was indeed conducted
properly
a question that came up is what if one
verifier says
everything is good and the other verify
another verifier says it's not
um and the answer to that
is that verifiers should not
just say yes or no yes is a perfectly
good answer
i've checked everything the selection is
good has no problems all the artifacts
check out
but just no is not an adequate answer a
verifier that just says no there's a
problem without specifying what the
problem is
should be ignored a verifier should
instead
if it finds a problem be very very
specific
about what the problem is and say
that this particular artifact is
supposed to
do this according to the spec and it
doesn't and it could
actually go right down to a single
operation and say
the specification says that
these two values should add together to
form this third value and they don't
you can think of an election record as a
spreadsheet
an election verifier is just going
through all the cells of the spreadsheet
and make sure that all the equations
that calculate all the cells
are indeed correct so these are the main
things that need to be done
and we hope that in coming years we'll
see
many instances of verifiers
verifying you used for verifying
many elections using this technology so
that voters can have
better control better better confidence
in the elections
and can can check they don't have to
depend on others they don't have to
depend
on equipment
or hardware or software or even people
out of
their control to
check that you know check the integrity
of the election
they can check it themselves or they can
choose
who they want to trust and and proxy
their trust in that way
so again thank you everyone for
your time and
we have some additional resources that
are in the bottom
right of your uh your window
that you can look at or you can look me
up
and get in touch with me if you have
some further questions
that that you'd like answered um i may
try to reach out to individuals um if
there are questions that i wasn't able
to answer
um but um i i hope that you you found
this of interest
and i hope that you will vote in your
next election
that you'll vote in november if you're
in the u.s or wherever
else you are at every opportunity and
that you'll be able to vote with
confidence
thank you very much have a good day
you